sandbox is a formally I have to say
utterly despised rehearsal space well
hated to play in here but now this
cavernous room is the hottest new
performance space for the San Francisco
Symphony it's called
sound box and what makes this place
possible is the same thing that makes it
seem impossible terrible acoustics so if
you look around the space here all of
the walls and the ceiling are treated
with a thick absorptive material so even
though this room is pretty large it
actually doesn't sound very large it
sounds really small that can be very
unsatisfying as a musician to perform in
and unsatisfying for the audience -
although it is really beneficial for
controlling sound that's where the sound
system comes in sound box uses a system
that can adjust the acoustics of the
room with a touch of a button well a few
buttons so right now we're in the
constellation setting tall Cathedral and
I'll clap so you can hear the
reverberation and now we'll turn the
system off and I'll clap so you can hear
how unrepented is
so the way it works is we have 28
microphones overhead and 85 loudspeakers
overhead and on the walls and so in real
time it's cycling the sound through the
space adding reflections as if the walls
were further out as if the ceiling were
taller and as if the surface material
were hard instead of soft and absorptive
having a space where the acoustics can
be customized so precisely let's the
Symphony perform a diverse array of
music here so for playing a piece from
Middle Ages that was performed
originally in a Cathedral we can change
the sound in this room to have the sort
of delay and roll-off that would exist
in an actual Cathedral and if we go to a
very contemporary piece that was
designed to be done in a studio perhaps
with complete flat instantaneous kind of
acoustic we can also do that on anything
in between while this level of sound
manipulation may not sit right with some
traditional symphony goers almost
everything about sound aux defies
tradition
instead of assigned seats you can sit on
an ottoman or just stand up the bar
doesn't just serve drinks at
intermission you can get a cocktail
anytime sandbox is a very free space
it's a kind of play space kind of
laboratory it's kind of prototype we're
testing out what experiences might be
part of the concert going experience the
symphony puts on five programs per year
at sound docks the space only
accommodates 500 people and tickets
generally sell out within a couple of
hours of going on sale my very dear old
friend Frank Gehry has said that he was
fortunate enough to live in a time when
technology finally caught up to where
his dreams had always been and that's
what I'm experiencing now as well
[Music]
you